>>> ANOTHER VERDICT HAS JUST
BEEN REACHED OVER AT THE TEXAS
TRIAL OF ALEX JONES.
JURORS TASKED WITH DECIDING HOW
MUCH JONES SHOULD PAY IN WHAT
ARE CALLED PUNITIVE DAMAGES TO
THE PARENTS OF A 6-YEAR-OLD WHO
WAS KILLED IN THE SANDY HOOK
MASSACRE.
YESTERDAY A JURY AWARDED THE
PARENTS MORE THAN $4 MILLION IN
WHAT ARE CALLED COMPENSATORY
DAMAGES.
OUR NATIONAL CORRESPONDENT
MIGUEL MARQUEZ IS JOINING US
RIGHT NOW.
SO JUST MOMENTS AGO, THE JUDGE
ANNOUNCED THE VERDICT.
GIVE US THE LATEST.
>> Reporter: $45.2 MILLION.
ON THREE DIFFERENT QUESTIONS.
THE JURORS WERE ASKED TO
CONSIDER, $4.2 MILLION FOR ONE
AND $20.5 MILLION FOR THE OTHER
TWO QUESTIONS.
LAWYERS ON BOTH SIDES ARGUING
TODAY THAT THEY BROUGHT IN A
FORENSIC ECONOMIST, LAWYERS FOR
THE PLAINTIFFS, THAT IS THE
PARENTS OF JESSE LEWIS, A
6-YEAR-OLD KILLED ALMOST TEN
YEARS AGO AT SANDY HOOK
ELEMENTARY.
HE WAS ONE OF 26 PEOPLE KILLED
THERE.
20 OF THEM CHILDREN.
ALL OF THEM UNDER 7.
THE MAIN THRUST OF THIS CASE IS
THAT MR. JONES THROUGH HIS INFO
WARS AND VARIOUS COMPANIES, LIED
ABOUT SANDY HOOK, LIED SAYING
THAT IT NEVER HAPPENED.
SAYING THAT THE PARENTS WERE
CRISIS ACTORS AND THAT KIDS LIKE
JESSE LEWIS DIDN'T EVEN EXIST.
YESTERDAY THE JURY AWARDED
$4.1 MILLION IN COMPENSATION.
TODAY THIS IS PUNITIVE, SO THIS
IS THE PUNISHMENT IS WHAT THE
JURY IS SAYING OF $45.2 MILLION
FOR MR. JONES.
NOW THERE IS A LOT OF QUESTIONS.
BECAUSE THEY HAVE THAT FORENSIC
ECONOMIST UP, THEY WENT UP TO --
THROUGH ALL OF HIS VARIOUS
COMPANIES, TRYING TO UNDERSTAND
HOW MUCH MONEY HE ACTUALLY HAD.
THAT ECONOMIST THOUGHT HIS
COMPANIES WERE WORTH ANYWHERE
BETWEEN $135 MILLION AND
$270 MILLION.
BUT IT IS NOT CLEAR THAT ALL OF
THAT MONEY IS THERE.
HE HAS NINE DIFFERENT COMPANIES
THAT HE RUNS MONEY THROUGH.
AND IN 2021 HE STARTED MOVING
MONEY OUT OF THOSE COMPANIES AS
THERE WERE SIMILAR LIABILITY
LAWSUITS THAT HE LOST REGARDING
SANDY HOOK IN CONNECTICUT, ALSO
IN TEXAS.
SO IT IS THE OTHER THING THAT IS
COMPLICATING ALL OF THIS IS THAT
THE STATE OF TEXAS HAS A CAP OF
STATE LAW THAT CAPS SOME OF THE
PUNITIVE DAMAGES SO IT'S NOT
CLEAR.
IT IS GOING TO BE A WHILE BEFORE
THE COURTS AND ALL SIDES SORT
THIS OUT.
HOW MUCH ACTUALLY WILL GO TO THE
PARENTS OF JESSE LEWIS.
BUT RIGHT NOW, A VERY BIG NUMBER
OF $45.2 MILLION IN PUNITIVE